for more on the latest let's go to the
border
in del rio the national border patrol
council president
brandon judd joins me where the
governors of florida and texas will be
there but brandon first
thanks for taking time for joining us
let me build upon jonathan series
last part of his report they're talking
about the
possible lifting of title 42 when i
looked at these numbers
i looked in the rgv sector particularly
the hardest hit area
if the other than mexican
non-unaccompanied children now that's a
little technical there but that's
basically
single adults that aren't from mexico
those from the northern triangle
up more than 756 percent
does that trend worry you when you look
at the possibility of lifting title 42
it's one of the biggest worries that we
have right now when you talk about
getting rid of title 42 and you're
talking about an
unprecedented crisis that we've never
seen before and when we're dealing with
so many people from around the world not
just mexico
not just the northern triangle but from
around the world and when you talk about
getting rid of title 42 all you're doing
is inviting more and more people to come
in the numbers continue to go up month
after month which clearly shows that the
biden administration does not care about
border security
and therefore he does not care about the
safety and security of the american
public
so when we talk about why people cross
our border illegally we look at the push
factors
the poverty the security situation gangs
violence in their home countries
and the pull factors which is incentives
like the likelihood that an
administration can be friendly to them
when you say the administration doesn't
care are you specifically
pointing to the fact that they are not
addressing that pull
factor of the fact that so many are
coming
the push factors have always existed in
these countries
the pull factor is what has has been
missing and that's what this
administration has done
they've brought back catch and release
that is the magnet that is drawing so
many people to come here illegally
when we're releasing as many people as
what we've done in the past
they're of course incentivizing illegal
immigration
and when you reward people for violating
the law
you can expect more people to do exactly
that
when you look at the june numbers 188
829 in may 180
000 plus you are seeing numbers that we
have not seen
in more than 20 years
walk it out for me brandon what happens
if this doesn't be under control in
reality we've never seen these numbers
before when we talk about fiscal year
you've got to remember that three of
those months were under president trump
and those months were low months
but when you look at a calendar year we
are on pace to set record numbers for a
calendar year
we've never seen month over month over
month
rises like what we're seeing today so
this is the biggest crisis that we've
ever faced
we've never faced uh the number of
people from other countries that we're
seeing right now
so this clearly is an administration
driven issue and the administration just
isn't doing anything to fix it
and we can expect it to get worse when i
was there where you are in del rio a
month ago
in a week of spend time there was
apprehensions of more than 35 countries
for the month it was more than 70. you
have governor desantis coming from
florida you will be at the meeting with
governor abbott and governor desantis
what do you know about the trip and what
will the governor see
uh desantis that is that's so important
well this just shows you how bad this
problem is the number of drugs are
entering our country
killing our children the cdc just came
out and said that we've never had more
drug
overdose deaths than what we're seeing
right now governor desantis is worried
about his state he's worried about
the problems that cross our border
illegally and go into his state
and there are several other governors
across the country because they know
it's not just affecting texas arizona
california new mexico it's affecting
every state in this country
and if we don't get this under control
it's going to continue to get worse and
the problem is
is this is an easy solution this isn't
something that takes a lot of work
to get under control this administration
just doesn't have the political will to
do it
brandon florida is a handful one of a
handful of states and governors who have
pledged support
resources national guard troops to
governor avenue and texas
do you believe as someone who is on the
operational side of this
you know will that help what can it do
to help try and perhaps get things under
control
it will help us as far as the number of
got away so not only are we arresting
more people than we've ever seen before
but we're having more people get away
than we've ever seen before as well
and that's what's going to help but the
problem is is they can't do anything
about the catch and release that has to
be an administration solved
issue we can put as many people on the
border as we want and we're going to
arrest
a record number of people but if they
continue to let them go
people are going to continue to come and
that is the number one problem
have you been invited to the white house
have you met with either vice president
harris or
president biden about this crisis
i have not and that's what's so
disappointing about this
they only care about their base they're
only listening to their base they're not
going to listen to people that are going
to give them
actual advice um somebody that has
endorsed democrats and republicans alike
that's myself
you know you would think that they would
want that perspective they would want a
perspective
from the ground from from boots on the
ground what's actually going on what
needs to be done
but because they do not have the will to
solve this problem
they're not going to invite people like
myself
to give them the advice that they need
in order to get this under control
and lastly just about 30 seconds there
brandon but i want to talk about the
increasing number of criminal migrants
that are being apprehended we see on
twitter
the secretary chiefs putting it out how
big of a problem
is that that's another thing that we've
never seen before
this is again we're breaking records in
every single category
we're seeing more uh sex crime
people that have been arrested for sex
crimes we're seeing more people that
have been wanted for murder we're seeing
more people that have committed violent
crimes
in this country that are crossing the
border illegally again this is a problem
that can be solved
this administration just doesn't have
the will and griff if you don't mind i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
somebody very special in my life my
mother um she supports um um border
security 100
i appreciate you allowing me to do that
happy birthday
mama judd thank you for raising a son
that dedicated himself to service i know
it's overwhelming for the agents there
because everyone i talk to is
overwhelmed in this situation brandon
judd
in del rio thank you for taking time
thank you griff